just when we are relieved right there's
gonna be another obstacle down the road
but at least we bought us some time well
and that's we've been the key all along
Greece can never pay this money back I
mean let's be honest Lee given the state
of the Greek economy the size the debt
they never pay it back but I think the
hurt the whole logical strategy really
for the last few years is string Greece
along nurse Greece long for long enough
for the rest of the periphery and the
rest of the European economy to get
healthy and for the European banks to
get healthy and we're actually a lot of
moving a good deal along that road right
now I think Europe is picking up
countries like ours are doing better
Spain is doing better Italy's doing a
little bit better so if you're can
continue to improve even if the Greek
situation remains critical you know the
longer we go the less dangerous it's
going to be greased eventually does have
to leave you but David it's been a
five-year Greek drama already right so
how much longer how many more years
before you're really gets back on
footing and says okay we can finally get
this get this done well I mean it is it
is tragic and I do feel very sorry for
the Greek people because I'll honestly
Europe ought to have been a little bit
more generous at the outset austerity in
the middle of recession is not ever a
good idea so it was a bad policy from
the start but we wanted to enforce some
discipline well yes but but but in fact
in fact what they ended up with of
course was with the election of an
extreme left-wing party increased
because of it and in fact the great
worry now in Europe the biggest worry
left is that extremist Left parties will
win elsewhere in Europe because the
public just doesn't trust European
institutions at all so I think it's I
think it's important that that we don't
have a full-blown crisis in Greece but
the resolution they hold that going
forward on enforcing more enforcing
these stringent austerity measures
holding the Greeks to those should they
step back from a little bit but I think
they can negotiate with Greece it's I
mean the one thing that we've learned
the last few weeks is even this new
serisa government realizes that they
don't have any cards in their hand right
I mean it's very hard to butcher to go
all-in when you've got nothing in your
hand and the Greek negotiating position
is getting weaker and weaker and weaker
and that's really why they capitulated
right on the
day of the election and it was a weekend
and it was much stronger back in two
thousand twelve when Franklin European
banks were in much worse trouble and
they are right now but but now that
that's not so much of a problem Greece
doesn't have that much of a trash but
here's where they might have leveraged a
Larry Fink of Blackrock I thought
outlined it very well and I want to play
for you David what he said about what
leverage Greece does have here in 2010
if Greece failed then the private sector
own most of the Greek debt today seven
th percent of the Greek debt is held by
the ECB Greek banks they're all part of
that and then then you have the IMF who
own has a huge loan outstanding to
Greece so it's not a private sector
problem there's more skin in the game
well it but it's not a private sector
problem and that that's really the point
I mean ultimately some of this debt is
bad and i think that the European
Central Bank and the IMF will take a hit
from it eventually but if that's far
enough down the road if that's when
unemployment has come down in Europe I
minutes the Greek debt is a lot for the
Greeks it's still not enormous in terms
of global economy or even in terms of
European economy so it's a hit but it's
a hit that's going to be much more
palatable for Europe if it could be
delayed by a few more years rather than
having it right now so here in the US
David have we avoided the catastrophe
are we free and clear I think a lot of
our worries are going away you know I
think we still got a fiscal cliff debate
over the Department of Homeland Security
this week but I think political forces
will force them to an agreement here the
u.s. is really getting better you know
we've got shot obviously lousy weather
up in Boston where I live but you can
get past this this this freeze consumers
are very well positioned lower gasoline
prices are helping I think housing will
improve so the u.s. is getting better
and I think that will ultimately support
the stock market and higher interest
rates this year